German products sell well around the
world that's great for Germany because
exports create jobs and bring money into
the country in the countries that import
German goods however it means fewer jobs
and money leaving the country when
exports exceed imports the result is a
current account surplus for several
years now Germany's has exceeded the EU
limit of six percent which is designed
to prevent imbalances last year Germany
exported goods worth almost 1.1 trillion
euros while imports amounted to only
about nine hundred six billion that puts
the current account surplus at 190
billion euros now the EU Commission has
announced it plans to take a closer look
at German economic data a high surplus
does not necessarily mean that there is
an imbalance but you do need to examine
this further and understand whether the
high surplus in Germany is something
that is affecting the functioning of
European economy as a whole there's been
growing criticism of German economic
policies one complaint is that wages are
too low low wages help make German goods
competitive but they also mean Germans
have less money to spend some economists
say higher wages could help close the
current account surplus but many here in
Germany reject the criticism they say
Germany is successful because it makes
high-quality products
you